en 2001 alicia por el yo trabajaba en un
banco y recuerdas claramente las
protestas de diciembre de ese año cuando
en medio de una gran crisis económica
social y política el gobierno impuso
restricciones al acceso de los ahorros
de los ciudadanos el llamado corralito
esto era una zona de guerra gente
corriendo
y los gases yo lo que me acuerdo eran
los gases que no podía ver lo peor llegó
el 20 de diciembre luego de que el
gobierno decretara el estado de sitio
para intentar poner fin a las protestas
que no se detuvieron una fuerte
represión se desató y cobró la vida de
39 personas entre ellas la pareja de
maría arena gastón venía desde 9 de
julio
hacia por avenida de mayo hacia tacuary
que es esta esquina
y cuando estaba en la esquina todavía de
9 de julio
un manifestante se acercó y le dijo
espera no vaya solo porque la arrancaba
la moto como para avanzar solo y gastón
le dijo venir súbita
esta persona se subió con él
50 metros lo mataron
lo ocurrido en 2001 dejó consecuencias
tan grandes que existe una suerte de
acuerdo en la política argentina para
evitar a toda costa que eso se repita
eso es una pérdida de mínima el que se
propone la política argentina que no
explote pero la realidad es que igual
hace 10 años de la argentina vive una
micro crisis en cuotas que está
deteriorado todos los niveles de
ingreso y todo en lo que es el poder de
compra los argentinos hace un montón con
lo cual la crisis y está sucediendo
igual y yo creo que ese sistema el 2001
está un poco contra las cuerdas
muchos creen que el país no ha terminado
de resolver los grandes desafíos y
deudas que quedaron pendientes desde esa
gran crisis y mariah arena tiene una muy
concreta la justicia 20 años después no
hay nadie preso por la muerte de su
pareja